to get the walkie-talkie so let's see if
she's ready to talk to us hello Tara can
you hear us
hello Tara here is Monica on board the
Sirius we can see your life raft but we
cannot yet hear you do you receive my
signal
that's certainly an interesting start to
the mission I'll give it one more go
hello Tara I'm on Channel 15 and
hopefully you have that same channel and
you're ready to talk to us we just want
to know how you're holding up
well the good news is that we can see
the land craft which we wouldn't in real
life but then again this is a
demonstration and we know that she's on
there so let's just assume that she
could hear us one last try
and I keep pressing the right button I
hope Terra yours Monica can you hear me
apparently she doesn't feel like talking
and I can't blame her for that so
hopefully what she will have done by now
is activate the distress beacon and just
in order to show you how that would work
I've got one here so this is one of
those 406 megahertz questions that she
has on her life raft as well she opens
it like this with two hands hopefully
there we are
unleashes this and there you are
this is a bit like a mobile phone so it
has all the data in there it can encode
to the position and send it then to our
Galileo satellite at 23,000 altitude
this little thing here can transmit
life-saving signals this is quite
amazing it cost about 200 euros and I'm
sure it's money well-spent certainly if
I was on this life raft I would love to
have one of those so this is activated
and keeps sending now the signal and the
signal as I mentioned earlier will be
received by the ground stations and then
passed on to Mission Control centers and
I assume that you will now see footage
of Toulouse where the sorry Galileo do I
get a second one we'll try again I'll
get a different walkie-talkie and we
just try again so let's rewind and go
back to Terra can you hear me here's
Monica on board the series
but maybe there are too many mobile
phones on here I don't know but I cannot
hear a thing this is the right way she
should hear me but who knows maybe worse
doesn't work and she doesn't have a
second one like I do
all right I think I'm very positive
because she's she knows what she's doing
I'm pretty positive that she has
launched the signal by now and I hope
that we get the footage of Toulouse I
hope you're watching this already where
we look at the sorry Galileo ground
segment it's organized in Europe with
the Sanwa nationality - especially in
Toulouse that is Canessa
they coordinate the distress alerts in
the European zone and distribute them
through the cross paths at network to
provide beacon identification and
location information satellite down
links are processed by ground receiving
stations called mio local user terminals
there's a SAR Galileo data service
provider coordinating the me alludes
from Norway Cyprus and Spain and then
there's the French Mission Control
Center F MCC that's the one we'll be
watching out for the mission centre of
course besides that in Europe which uses
the French male lute and right now
they'll be busy looking for Tara's
distress signal - computer position and
then pass that information on to the
nearest rescue station and we're
basically waiting for the signal now
provided she has activated the beacon we
couldn't speak to her by the way that
helicopter that you can hear brother
play and maybe sometimes see this is not
yet a helicopter to rescue Tara this is
a helicopter to take footage to film
this whole rescue operation so don't let
this confuse you so I'm basically
waiting now to have confirmation that
the signal was received provided it was
launched which I cannot check right now
because the only way to communicate with
Tara was through the walkie-talkie and
she didn't respond so we just have to
wait and see what I can tell you is that
the signal should be localized about one
and a half minutes after the beacon was
activated then it takes a good minute
later in order to have the first
confirmation of their position
and then a few minutes later there'll be
an update of the confirmation and the
reason for that is that as you can see
that life raft behind me is drifting it
is completely exposed to the elements so
the first position that we get might
change and so there has to be a
confirmation so they can narrow the area
down to the most precise location before
they launch the rescue operation now as
we're waiting and waiting and waiting
that is part and parcel of a live
demonstration
perhaps I can introduce you to a
gentleman who is actually to a large
part responsible also for Galileo and
the cameraman keeps trying to signal
something but I would like to talk to
this gentleman now
so Paul flama if you could join me now
he's a part of the European Commission
head of unit program management galileo
first of all how you're holding up it's
a it's moving moving a lot today there
is a lot of swell so but it's very
interesting that makes the demonstration
interesting I think live conditions it's
but it's also interesting that it's life
that things don't run 100% smoothly that
every life wouldn't be like that either
yes in real life accidents can happen
this test can happen and this is what we
are trying to do here today what I'm
pretty happy about is that in terms of
rescue operation things are going okay
it seems that maybe we have some
problems with videos or sound but for
the rest things are going according to
plans and video and sound that is not
crucial to saving somebody's life that's
so let's talk a little bit about the
Galileo search and rescue service and
the satellites included in all that so
how does this fit into european space
program as a whole
okay so satellite navigation and galileo
is our european satellite navigation
is made over 26 satellite 24 which do
carry equipment which allow for rescuing
people
so therefore if there is a distress at
sea the people just simply trigger a
beacon and the signal are then taken up
by our 24 Galileo satellites and that
allows for the detection of distress
action and the satellites are then able
to localize from where that distress
signal was emitted and once the
detection of the position has been found
then it is transmitted to the rescue
centers which come and help the people
who are in distress
so basically Galileo is providing
positioning information we have several
services and this search and rescue
service is one which fits very well with
the technology and the infrastructure we
have developed now I can just see there
is a some movement happening behind us
there is another boat with some divers
there at the life raft so I'm not quite
sure maybe they're trying and so solve
the problem with the walkie-talkie maybe
there is another problem so we'll just
keep observing what's happening behind
for what I can see they are the beacon
the beacon has been activated so at
least we've got that confirmed now so we
know now it'll take about a minute a
minute and a half until hopefully in
Toulouse they will say we've got it yes
what is very nice with Galileo is that
some the search-and-rescue function of
galeano works 24 hours a day all over
the globe so far the organisation which
was in charge of search and rescue
operation used and this organization is
called cosmos assets they were using
satellites which were in very low Earth
orbit so if you had no satellite above
your head maybe you were activating your
beacon but the signal was not detected
and I'm just hearing that they are
indeed in Toulouse glued to the screen
and we should get the first signal any
moment let's watch and listen
apparently we didn't just get to the
signal apparently we also already got
the confirmation of the update and it
took three minutes and 32 seconds from
Terra activating the beacon to the
moment when the rescue center in this
case the maritime rescue control center
in Ostend there could start the rescue
mission 3 minutes 32 that is quite
amazing it is not only quite amazing but
in the past some of those beacons were
activated but never detected by any
satellites since 2016 when Galileo
became operational no we are hundred
percent sure that there will always be
coverage wherever you are
so which really is good news for the
people who are sailing and having
problems at sea so that that is really
an achievement and a progress for for
the maritime sector and it is a European
achievement with a lot of different
players and it took many years to get it
off the ground and it will last for many
many decades to come
it maybe took some years at the
beginning in order to convince European
government to set up infrastructure like
Galileo but once this has been decided I
think we can be proud that it it really
took shape pretty quickly as I said
since 2016 the system is operational
it was developed thanks to the help of
the European Space Agency the European
member states decided to to put the
program in the hands of the European
Commission with the technical help of
the European Space Agency and we have
now created an agency in Prague in the
Czech Republic which is operating the
system exploiting the system making sure
that it's gonna be used by the whole
world and 10 days ago we even announced
that we already had 1 billion users for
Galileo or so which is very fast in
terms of market take-up and perhaps the
last one because this is a system that
is now up and running
it should be up and running for many
many decades and probably evolve and get
even better do we have the right people
not only we have the right people but
for example for search and rescue
operation we will provide as of next
year as of the moment the Council of
Coast passes that we will allow this
kind of operation the people at sea in
this place will also get a message from
the rescue centers that the distress
message has been received and that there
are some rescue operations taking place
coming to rescue them so this is an
improvement of the previous technology
which did not allow this kind of return
link as we call it
okay thank you very much because I've
just been informed that not only the
rescue boat the Orca 6 r6 has already
left in order to - towards the life raft
antara
but it also the helicopter at the coxy
base it's an age ninety goes by the dead
caiman is also ready to launch - come to
Terrace assistance and I hope because we
do have some of the big decision makers
here on board the series actually here
on the bridge we have captain efficient
pissants she's the head of the maritime
Rescue Coordination Center in Ostend we
have captain Kevin de Poissy he's the
operations manager Coast so he's a
charge of the Orca rescue boat and we
have a corner Stefan
Holbrook he's the base commander at coxy
there so he's in charge of the
helicopters and hopefully they come and
join me in a very short period of time
because I would like to find out from
them is happening right now because we
don't have live footage here I cannot
yet see the boat and I cannot yet here
the Ella copter but I can see that we
already have
captain occasion he sends here and and
she is in charge of the MRC see if you
would like to to join me right now and
the cameraman always tells us because
obviously he wants to keep an eye on the
boat on the of the life raft we're on
the boat
so efficient this is quite exciting even
though it is just a demonstration right
it's correct it's just a demonstration
with we are keen to see in the results
of it we are hoping we will receive at
the MRCC in Ostend the distress signal
within the five minutes has been told to
us the life raft is life behind us the
weather is rather rough so we hope
signal is received in very do and very
quick time so we can send out our assets
of flying and surface assets to rescue
the lady in the life raft when this
normally happens in the RCC is it a sort
of peaceful and calm mood or is
everybody very agitated just sort of
just talk as a little bit through about
what happens there well the people in
the RCC they will receive the emergency
signal coming from F MCC to lose and
they will take immediately action
because it's a distress signal they will
try to come in contact with the life
raft with the person in distress and if
they can't come in contact with the
person moving a bit we're moving a bit
we're on the sea I put out my sea legs
they will try to come in contact with
the person who's in distress and if it's
not possible probably at the emergency
they will receive the exact position
accuracy of two kilometres and send out
as quickly as possible the surface and
the airborne assets to see what's going
on and see what kind of a citizens they
have to do and I can I can say that we
already have certainly when it comes to
the airborne assets we already have
currents they found a whole book here
the base commander of Kok CD if you
would like to join us as well and I just
sort of move a little bit and again our
cameraman will tell you tell us when
we're in the way so the first thing that
is actually being sent out in this
rescue operation is the boat the rescue
boat the Orca when does the helicopter
come into play what the signal is sent
to the boat we are the satellites to
Toulouse and then to msec
the maritime Rescue Coordination centre
then well the the sense of tasks and the
boat and the copter
and ricotta will he see the information
from our pink application center and
within the 20 minutes after the signal
is Campbell we should be able to perform
the search and rescue and I just just
hearing the boat so the rescue boat not
us not a series is leaving right now so
the boat is getting there first
to do what well if the boat is set out
it means the emergency call was received
at TM RCC they will direct it to the
person to the victim who's in distress
they will TK what's going on they will
do an inspection required the woman
who's on board what's going on if she's
in distress if she's ill if she's six
and after that if it's necessary for a
medical evacuation our colleagues from
the rescue oxidant probably they will
hand over the person to the helicopter
who will bring over the person to
hospital here in the vicinity
so you basically you would be on standby
because maybe your services are not
required and I hear the helicopter is
required in this particular situation
once we are required well this tremor
bell ring and in that case the pilots
the crews because of people five people
on board two pilots flight engineer
cabin operator diver and a nurse
we're scrambled to Delhi copter and
within 20 minutes they are supposed to
be airborne on to join the rescue scene
during the flight transit flight till
the scene they receive more information
via MSS a also and once on target then
research we start with the search
operations once the target is found then
we can go over to the rescue operation
let's talk a bit about the rescue
preparation because once the helicopter
arrives and I've just been told that
it's on its way now it will get very
very noisy here and we won't be able to
hear anything so we have the rescue boat
here the rescue boat determining in
which shape tara is you have the
helicopter arriving what exactly is
happening then from the moment when the
helicopters hear my DM is to bring the
patient or the victim as soon as
possible to a hospital - first you have
to get it the victim off the life raft
yes so we have to pick up the the victim
to bring it as soon as possible to
sanitary to hospital to take care of the
people who was in the water tell us a
little bit about the winching up because
I spoke to Tara before we headed out and
she says she's perfectly all right with
everything but the winching up is
somewhat makes her feel a bit queasy why
yeah specific operation especially with
this type of helicopter it's a 11 ton le
copter very heavy and doing a lot of
don't wash to the to the divers and to
the people that has to be rescue so it's
very impressive for the people hanging
under the this winch to be Winship and
to be picked up to the Li copter and I
can see we turn around we can see the
rescue pod to Orca just now circling or
circling in on the life raft are they
going to open it up and pull her out
well they will open for of course the
life rafts to see if somebody is inside
they will examine the persons who are
inside the life raft this information
they will hand over to the MRC sea and
the emergency in Ostend will take
contact with the aera sea-cocks it to
pass this information as well and this
information is passed to the helicopter
where they have a medic on board
so the medic who's joining the the
helicopter he has already a little
knowledge what he might expect on board
of the life raft I mean how often I just
say your crew how often do they have to
go out and see and rescue people in this
area for medical evacuations we have in
total on a yearly base
about an average of 30 persons for a
medical evacuation in the Belgian waters
in total in a yearly base we have about
400 incidents as an average and now they
can look forward to the fact that
everything will go faster as we just
heard from activating the signal to the
launch of the rescue operation it was
three minutes 32 seconds if I remember
correctly but like was three and a half
and normally it would take about four
hours that makes life easier also for
the rescue crew doesn't it well when
you're in danger you have to tell the
Rescue Coordination Center that you're
in the injury have
means to do that one of those things is
use of an e / an ELT personal locator
beacon with the 406 megahertz beacon
when it's activated and captured by the
Galileo satellites and transmitted to
the MRC in four minutes instead of four
hours well that makes it much more
quickly and the chance to find the
people to survive let's say you have a
bigger chance to survive if we just see
if when we see the camera I'm sure we'll
pick it up right now
as the boat is sort of stopping
alongside the life raft you really see
how choppy the sea is that it is not
smooth at all that is a very rough day
weather-wise with windy and waves but I
can see that terror is lifted onboard
the rescue boat or car so I just saw her
head I think they got her on board now
and leave the life what happens to the
life raft by the way after this the life
raft will be picked up and if it's not
possible for picking up the life raft
the rubbers will be cut so no other
persons or other passing vessels might
think there's another person in distress
but normally it will be picked up or
towed to the port of Austin but for sure
we won't leave it at sea monkeys I have
to I just saw how choppy that was when
they had to take her out and the the
Orca lifeboat actually sort of sort of
somewhat got very close to the water in
this position now when you have the
helicopter which is sort of then
hovering around them how low does it go
up to 80 to 100 feet not lower than that
to avoid too much down wash on the on
the crew and on the ship so it's pretty
high in fact to limit the effect of
downwash on the on the victims at first
you have to have a diver I believe and a
medic to go down and they have to
actually hit the boat and not the waves
next to it in function of what receiver
of information from the MRC see if
somebody is injured or not injured
we had dropped the diver or the diver
which
the rescue mans or the medical nurse in
that case I think we only dropped
without the diver to pick up the victim
and you just because I can see I can
hear this helicopter you just make sure
that when the real helicopter the caiman
is arriving you will let me know we'll
be talking about the cruise going out
there I mean this is a this is a calling
you don't just turn into a rescue crew
member be it for helicopters or in in
your rescue center you're not doing that
for pay I mean what sort of people
decide to do the kind of job that you're
doing why we need some motivate people
that that like to take some risks of
course that like to go to fly over water
because most of the missions that we do
are over over water it's also a trainer
that takes that possibility three years
before they are accurate with two
Friday's ready copter had to perform the
mission and they are also to be standby
24/7 the whole year true so it's a it's
a job that needs some sacrifices and
some some personal motivation to do it
and it is world maritime day today I was
told and the motto this year is to
empower women in in maritime professions
maritime circumstances why is that
important well it's good all jobs are
open for women and for men so it's
important to attract women for a life at
sea so they can join and do the same
profession as a man at sea
how many women work with you I think you
you told me you were the first woman in
charge of an mrsec in Belgium so how
many more are they now three women two
operators well motivated operators
working at the MRC sea
I'm in charge of the MRC sea since 10
years but my first profession was being
a sailor for the merchant shipping and
of course on this very important day
also we have with with Tara our also
female volunteer would you be doing that
I could do it or so but we have also
females in our crews we have ten pilots
capable to do in search-and-rescue
operations and out of this ten we have
one female that is doing as well as the
other boys so what is happening now with
Orca Orca is waiting for the helicopter
to arrive and in the meantime they try
and make the person they rescued feel
good is there any more communication
going on yes there's continuously going
a common communication because on the
shore site where you have the emergency
where you have the sub center of cook
seed people want to gather as much as
possible information because other
partners have to be informed as well
like hospitals ambulances so sharing of
information is very important what
happens now on board of the Orca they
will do the first examination of the
victim they will pass through all this
information to the necessary surfaces if
additional assistance is required then
they will ask it as well and further
instructions will be passed by the
emergency to the helicopter and to the
Orca let's say for taking the the life
raft on tow they will ask if there's any
spill if there are any other persons who
are injured what happened exactly with
this lady washing on board of a vessel
all this information has to be gathered
to make sure that your story is complete
and how especially now also from from
the helicopter rescue side how has God
Galileo satellites and and their search
and rescue service how has this changed
if at all your work it will make the
part of the search in the search and
rescue operation the part of the search
more accurate in the form of times we
have to concentrate on the corner of 10
kilometers on 10 kilometers
now with that Godot system it will be
reduced to a corner of two on two
kilometers so it will easy the the the
search zone and the search time and so
we can go over more quickly to the to
the rescue operation well we had use the
time that the people is into the water
so whatever money a program like the
Galileo satellite service cost it's
worth it from your point of view but
from our side of you it's for sure worth
the less time we lose the better
position we have the more percentage of
a survival time it's always welcome for
everybody forever seaman all right then
let's just keep an eye out on the rescue
boat and have our eyes peeled to find
out where the helicopter is how far is
coccidia from here oxy this thirty
kilometers from here so flying time up
with the five minutes but we need the
time that took the crew Fitz itself that
jump to the into the copter start up it
takes 20 minutes so as for me I see the
scramble from the MRCC
24 25 minutes later we should be on
scene okay so we should see it fairly
soon then let's let's watch a little bit
and
[Music]
yes question sir can you go to the life
raft recuperate the PLP thing and shut
it down please
right on six to tritone 6 2 vertical
government
[Music]
okay doctor you have understood my
question and you will recuperate the POV
and shut it down
[Music]
thank you very much sir
Boston coast guard this is all cry over
our car awesome Coast Guard yes I
followed the conversations thank you
very much sir
right on 6 2006 two vertical guards come
in
right on six to try Tom six to thirteen
Coast Guard coming
Tritan pixel - sick - 34 government
[Music]
right on fix to the Belgian Coast Guard
yes we have a situation there's an
activation of a personal location beacon
and we just recovered this female person
person was in the water we have
something to copy ready to copy
[Music]
- six - this is the Belgian coast guard
the victim has been recovered by South
vessel Romania six força and the
following present position five on the
Greece one five decimal 2 3 north zero
zero two degrees five power decimal
three one is over
service assist of the title 6 to
developers evacuated by the Romeo 660
married
repeat the long lock position five one
degrees one five decimal two three North
zero zero two degrees
okay copied six two additional
information is this female person
disagrees he had some hypothermia but
now we are aware of the fact that she
has some burning woods in the face and
the arms so six two and the information
on the scene we have a south westerly
wind four seven and the helicopter the
nh90 the cayman helicopter is here we
can actually if you can see it it's
approaching now from seed airbase
about 23 kilometers you said or thirty
kilometers south of us and a so here it
comes now I've been told that this is
going to be very noisy so just to joke
our memory again so it comes in here and
it's going to do what I know it well as
seen the target well a circle are on
target to see where they can take the
best position for the pickup of the
victim then position itself preferably
into the wind to gain some lift and then
proceed with the winching operation to
pick up the victim on the boat I just
say also say that there are various
other vessels out at sea right now that
have nothing to do with our life
demonstrations these are just ordinary
vessels how do you deal with them you
have to somehow communicate with them as
well when something like this goes on
right yes we are doing we are
broadcasting a safety message
we are informing the vessels in the
vicinity they have to stay away from the
odka because we will do a winching
operation if it was necessary to have
extra vessels to give assistance we
might have called them to give extra
assistance but it's not necessary now
the only thing we are doing now is
giving passing them information they
have to keep clear from the Orca to do
the winching operation in a good order
so it's not like on a motorway when
there is an accident they're not all
stopping to watch there this is a very
sort of very straightforward procedure
that all the vessels the small and the
big ones I mean this is also a ferry
connection they all adhere to that well
if they heard an emergency call on the
channel 16 most of the vessels they will
call the MRC sea as well and ask him
then if they have to provide the systems
that might happen as well if they don't
ask it no problem but we inform all the
vessels in the vicinity to keep clear of
the position where the situation is
going on
it's something about that the here we
are exactly that it's approaching now in
order to get the winching up ready so to
basically winch Terah up but for that
the diver on the helicopter first has to
go down and there we again can see that
depending on the weather conditions I
mean it is windy today but you probably
have to perform this sometimes it even
worse conditions can-can the weather
conditions actually stop such a rescue
operation rescue operations are supposed
to take place in all possible kind of
weather so we take some some risks but
we are supposed to intervene and also
and worst weather conditions as possible
and we turned that for each day like
today which when also it's a each day
which we do the same exercise to winch
up somebody autofocus on so how do you
coordinate the helicopter up here and ok
down there they have to sort of somehow
be coordinated that the driver who goes
down actually hits the boat and as I
said not misses it how does that work in
fact there is a contact between the boat
and the de copter for the position and
to ask the boat to take a certain
directions so that the copter can
perform the winching into the wind and
then one once we have above we are above
the position to to start the winch was a
exercise at that time
the cabin operator of the flight
engineer on board is taking care of the
job of the the the diver
onto the boat at that time there is no
contact anymore between the ship and the
Dakota but it's the the the flight
engineer that has taken the controls of
this winch operation to drop the diver
on the boat because right now from me as
a sort of an amateur watching this it
looks like the boat is trying to get
away from the helicopter I think that
for the exercise here there are some
requests from the DES copy because in
the copter we have all sorts on camera
TV team requesting I think some
different positions to for the pictures
but not for it's not in that way that we
work normally
so that dance that dance that were
seeing there between the helicopter and
and the rescue boat Orca it doesn't have
to be that way this is this is a little
bit of show right now okay this is a
little bit of show but of course we want
to see something as we're out here and
actually it's it's getting is slightly
more choppy here even on board the
series and when I see out there I'm sure
that Tara will be looking forward to
being winched up on the helicopter
inside the helicopter and then flowing
back but the helicopter is certainly
coming lower now so I just look forward
to the moment when the diver goes out
and hangs in the air and searches the
boat I think it was still busy anything
with some camera shoots and some special
effects special effects but not for with
a real winching operation we can
probably check patient he has to go to
be above the boat of course and on the
side
but I also imagined that a helicopter
like this sort of hovering around would
create much more disturbance in the sea
but right now it sort of looks as if it
can Wow
it has very little influence on it we
don't see it from here but if you are if
you were under the the copter
you should feel affect the the effect of
the water of the downwash of the water
and then we have a very brave man there
presumably a man could also be a woman I
don't know I can't see that from here
but that's the diver going down there
yeah we have a team of eight
divers also taking of the 24/7 standby
all males we don't have any female diver
up to now over it can calm
we have also eight nurses and one of
them is also a female but most of the
crew are men on both of the year copter
now we see that the diver will try to
jump on the on the boat to to land and
to pick up the the victim that is no
waiting for forecast cue winching up
will be easier than the diver going down
trying to get the boat yes now the the
operator of the winch has now to take
care to put the diver on the right place
on this small ship but once we divert on
the ship it will be an easy operation to
pick him up and to bring him into the
copter it's more easy to winch the honor
to which more easy to reach chapter to
resolve
well you ever tempted to do something
like that no I'm happy with my job be
sure in the MRCC
better being in control and passing on
what needs to be done yeah that would
suit me better as well than watching
what I see it's an operation that we do
approximately for real than 80 times a
year eighty eight eighty approximately
eighty scrambles a year and we receive
absolutely forty to fifty live lives a
year and is it is there sort of a
specific part here in the channel where
it happens the most is there somewhere
where you say there's always a
completely arbitrary you know it can't
happen everywhere we have to pick up
people who are falling overboard from
merchant shipping from sailing vessels
from fishing vessels but we can have
people being sick who needs who require
a medical evacuation as well from
merchant vessels pleasure crafts and it
can happen everywhere in the area of
responsibility
but they don't have the 406 megahertz
cross passage beacon just yet today well
the merchant vessels as from a certain
gross tonnage
they must have these beacons eeper for
the pleasure craft the people they have
to wear a jacket and on top of the
jacket we all advise them to have an
emergency beacon in case of emergency
they can activate and broadcast safety
message or panthan or made a message
they are in danger because I mean we're
fairly close and we can see a lot but I
cannot see the details of what the draw
the diver is going to do with Tara now
she's already wearing a wetsuit would
she get an extra harness in order to be
winched up she will be taken in charge
by the diver so will she will hang at at
the diver and together they will be
winched up into the copter safely so see
what she will not be winched alone but
the diver will take with him but it's
not going to be a vertical lift because
we see that the boat and the helicopter
there they're not sort of in the same
line so there'll be a bit of sort of
flying because from here from the
perspective effect but we have a certain
kind of parallax and we have the
impression that they are not following
the same line but they do especially
when they are performing the winching
they have to be above the ship of course
now Tara is a volunteer so she will play
ball with whatever happens as it already
happened that you're trying to rescue
somebody and that person says I'm not
going up on that helicopter I mean what
you do in such a situation I don't
remember that we have met such a kind of
situation because I think that all
people that need to be rescue will be
happy to see the copter to be the dad to
see the diver because there were be
caught we wet so they want to be picked
up as soon as possible photo song to
have
some medical service that you see is the
enough 90 is a new record at what we
have in service since 2014 we have four
of them and we do especially
search-and-rescue operations but we do
also operation ship on operations for
the marine for the Belgian marine so
it's a copper that is that has a lot of
possibilities not only for you but also
for marine operations and the helicopter
seems to be shoot shooting off then we I
didn't see the the wind shop could you
see it
could you see her being pulled up there
I didn't see it but I think that some
taking some shoots to perform again a
landing on the ship because I didn't see
yet the winching up though there may be
she likes it on there maybe she doesn't
want to get off there how many of these
helicopters do you have because I mean
this one right now is used for a live
demonstration but a real emergency could
happen at the same time how many do you
have at your disposal yeah we have total
four helicopters a nationality and today
we have two the captive serviceable one
of them is no performing exercise for
Galileo and the other one is in standby
at coxide for Hill emergency
and your crew at the MRCC are they going
to follow this now or are they also busy
following right now real emergencies I
hope there is none but just in case
there was they are doing both they're
following this situation because they
still have to do some coordination even
it's an exercise if we have another
incident at the same time at the MRC
scene they will split up and one will
occupy himself with this situation and
the other person will occupy him with
the real incident but apart from that we
have the flying assets we have the
surface assets we have more surface
assets in the portal Blankenburg we can
use in the park of Newport and even in
the port of Austin's so in case we have
to scale up we can call other surface
assets as well you're well-equipped I'm
just trying to look through that window
screen to see if if I can see our our
volunteer victims somewhere hiding in
there maybe already enjoying a cup of
coffee or something while we're still
waiting for her to be winched up
okay so the helicopter is coming back
divers soldier protractor
diverse reporter can you hear me
from Parker if you can hear me the
personal locator blinking and still
transmitting three shut it down shut it
down
[Applause]
that's a good copy abetik zero and
looking like the real thing the
helicopter is certainly closing in and
they're there she's being pulled up
she's pulled up so she will be safe and
a few moments on both of Dede copter
this time she is alone as I see but
because the situation is not so
dangerous but and in general now in
shock with the help of the divers but in
that case I impression it would be alone
or it was the nurse that has been miss
Bishop now and we are still see a second
which I bet we have to confirm that once
we see the movement of the D copter
so how would the movement ah if it if it
leaves then it would be a confirmation
well what sign if it leaves now it means
that everybody has now Winship and on
board ready to go to the next station
but I can not confirm that from here I
don't see it too much
so we're basically now waiting to be
absolutely certain that it was Tara
being winched up and that Tara is in the
helicopter inside the helicopter safe
and sound
out so the medic I just get confirmation
it was the medic
okay and Tara will be next and maybe she
will not be on her own then we'll see
that that is something I hope she will
be
she's together with the diver that's
normal for sale used to be a pickup with
by the diaphragm and now they will be
safely into the deep copter and go to
the back to the home base
okay so I think we can be sure that
we've just seen Tara there with the
diver being winched up and pulled inside
the helicopter the helicopter now
leaving the scene rescue boat orca also
done its job
that means from that point of view from
the rescue point of view we can say
mission accomplished thank you very much
thank you very much I'd of course a big
thank you to the entire rescue crew this
was a live demonstration but
nevertheless the circumstances and all
the procedures were real and they just
saved our volunteer Tara foster they
took her of the life raft onto the
rescue boat orca r6 and from there
winched her up into the helicopter the
nh90 and what is the takeaway from the
moment she activated the 406 megahertz
cospas-sarsat beacon until the moment
the rescue operation was launched they
took a mere three and a half minutes
without the Galileo satellite service it
can take up to four hours and given the
roughness of the sea I would say that
Tara and all the victims who happen to
be in this situation will appreciate the
Galileo satellite service making things
shorter I certainly appreciate it thank
you very much for following our live
broadcast of operation shark bait
haven't seen any sharks but we got the
bait bye-bye
you
[Music]